hey I want to mention that John Hein
this is not my observation but a lot of
the guys came to me do you know about
high energy John know the theory around
here is there are two john hines there's
regular john hind that you hear on the
wrap-up show and high-energy john right
he's not high energy no no wrap-up show
is slightly higher energy john than you
get here but really we're the high
energy how we're hitting with the hind
came from is that sports show he turns
into a completely different what is this
boy let's give john a plug what is this
voice it's called loud mouth loud mouth
on SNY network is the regional mets
network so let's give everyone an
example of high energy job to hear
here's john from his TV show loud mouths
this gate thing it drives me up the wall
can we please put an end to adding a
gate to every single controversy that
happens in professional sports right it
was called watergate do you know why
because the name of the hotel was the
Watergate Hotel that makes sense all
these other gates it's lazy journalism
he's got opinions
he's well don't think powder
don't they powder his head for that term
oh yeah it's going to think that powder
has something in it with it you some
kind of peppy powder that's not the John
I know I can't even imagine him
producing that voice John I mean where
is this energy coming from is this a new
persona you're putting on well on the TV
show when it comes to that sports topic
I was I was pretty fired up for sure but
one thing I do want to clarify and I
think even Jason will admit it i I have
the same energy level on wrap-up as I do
on loudmouths I you do yeah absolutely
I've never seen you that fired up here
when is he ever yelled he's ever yelled
at me like that before
no not even about hit with a Chinese
undresses wacky for his television show
he wears Hawaiian shirts sometimes he
once dressed up his Woody from Toy Story
during Halloween and he even dressed up
as a leprechaun that is true yeah
there's a whole other thing I'm kind of
happy with the John hi and I have
because I like your natural
kind of energy well here humming I have
a different role you know when you're
normal well yeah well I'm in the back
you know I'm working on research and
taking social performance when you're on
this sport show yes and you're carrying
on like that see I think it's big
because okay we're looking at the broad
okay
John Hyde on the radio find this show is
different than John hainan S&Y but we're
outside of the office and talk to you
and I talk almost every morning about TV
or politics or sports and did john honai
here in the offices to john hind that
comes onto the shuttle I'm barely mooses
lips I tell people wait John Hines
standing right here hold on
this is dr. Jekyll and mr. the real John
hind please stand up this is you know
I'm starting to see there's a new
personality I'm getting to worry Robin
how many times have we put a mirror
under John Hines to make sure he's
breathing is it fair to say this is John
Hine gate this is a completely different
person
you